Luxembourg is a small country it's about
50 miles by 35 miles with just over
600,000 people living in it and here in
the capital Luxembourg City around
200,000 people commute into work every
day half from outside the country but
less than 20 percent of them travel by
public transit but from Sunday March 1st
all public transit in the entire country
will be free pretty soon there'll be no
ticket machines unless you want an
international ticket there'll be no fare
Dodgers unless you count people who are
sneaking into the first-class train
cabins that you will still have to pay
for and on the face of it free public
transit seems like an easy decision get
people out of cars and into buses and
trains but it's a little more
complicated than that we have the
country beside Qatar with the highest
degree of cars per household in
Luxembourg and we have definitely a big
problem in especially in peak hours with
enormous congestion problems we have a
problem also that quality of life in our
cities in our villages it's really
worsened that comes because luxembourg
is a country where you had not only the
highest average of economic growth in
the last 25 years but also our
population grows is the highest in the
european union having mobility behavior
that is mainly based on individual house
cannot really function anymore
and at the end is it's also a problem
then for our economy itself making
public transit free is not a new idea
there are quite a few cities around the
world who've already done it and a lot
of Estonia now has free public transit
for residents Luxembourg though is the
first country to abolish fares entirely
and partly that's because it can afford
to do it the countries are small rich
tax haven the thing is public transit
here is almost free already a ticket
valid for a full day on every bus tram
and train in the country is for Europe
the whole transit network costs the
government 700 million euro a year to
operate but all the tickets sold add up
to just 10% of that by comparison
london's transit network is about half
funded by fares so from the Luxembourg
government's perspective there's not
actually that much difference between a
four euro day ticket in free transit but
free transit is
a headline we get through a lot of good
publicity but hey if the transit is free
why do you want to get around by car
well it's because the transit here isn't
great it's okay by European standards
the buses and trains will get you there
I've had no problems as a tourist but
the commuter lines are already
overcrowded in rush-hour a lot of the
rolling stock is dated and there is a
litany of complaints about the paths
they take and how they deal with
breakdowns driving here even with the
congestion is usually quicker and more
convenient sometimes even for journeys
directly between city centers so every
year there's more and more people moving
here and the infrastructure system is
under a lot of strain so the needs are
to make it work not to make it free
there's lots of research on this and
what comes out over and over again is
that fair is not the main motivating
factor the motivating factor is comfort
reliability and safety no one never
knows if the trains are actually going
to be on time it has happened that
people are standing for an hour and a
half on the platform waiting for the
train with no substitute buses or
anything so that's an extreme case
obviously but if one wants to be
somewhere on time one has to take this
into account that these things do happen
the cities who are doing this invest in
the public transport in a free public
transport that really the be the cities
that from a competitive point of view
will be worldwide to winning cities even
if I say it's free to use somebody pays
it so at the end the 700 million euros
will be paid by the taxpayers in general
someone for example with a minimum
income pays no taxes so so he has the
public transport really for free but
somebody who pays high taxes he pays
much more that's the important point for
someone like me who's a tourist with a
travel budget for euro for a day pass
isn't a big issue but for someone on
minimum wage who has to commute an hour
or two hours from wherever housing is
affordable that makes a big difference I
don't think the key social issue in in
Luxembourg is the price at the Transit
one needs to look at the housing costs
the increasing prices of housing are
pushing people to the border regions so
it might be financially more sound to
live
Belgium or France in Germany buy a house
or rent a house and buy a couple of cars
then it would be to live here in
Luxembourg and use the transit it needs
investment and it needs investment now
it's behind and so Luxembourg needs to
catch up and plan for the future you
must see the the free public transport
additionally to the investments that we
are doing in the improvement of the
network and the quality of the public
transport if you only introduced free
public transport that really changed not
very much in your behavior it can only
function if you do it combined with a
complete strategy that will switch from
individual mobility to multi-modality so
even including pedestrians cyclists and
if you invest at the same time a lot of
money in the infrastructure of public
transport so that at the end you can
combine everything we say if we build an
infrastructure we will build it to move
people at that to move cars
I'm not saying free transit is a bad
thing I think it's a great idea
personally but having good frequent well
connected transit that isn't too crowded
aboard is also important
the question isn't as binary as should
public transit be free because in a
utopia of course it would be it would
also be autonomous the zero emission and
it would run from anywhere to everywhere
all the time
but until we're in a post-scarcity
society the public are paying one way or
another either through taxes or fares
the more important question is about
planning and long-term investment
because if your bus is always late and
your trains always cancelled it really
doesn't matter if they're free
you